everyone it is that time of the week
again for our live conversation where as
part of your day of the equation I'm
happy to cover anything that is equation
relating and of course since equations
are related to everything that means
everything is game so truly feel free to
ask me about anything that's on your
mind you know me if I don't know the
answer I'm straightforward I tell you if
I have something to say on the subject
I'm happy to offer it and let's begin as
we sometimes do and I see Luis has
already noted that he is in our
conversation from Mexico but I do like
to see the various places where
everybody is from so if you don't mind
just sort of saying where you're from I
would love to see that
and then as those countries roll by I
will be all too happy to start finding
the first questions and get moving on
things all right so what do we have here
what am I going to begin with uh there's
one question I really want to begin with
and I I didn't have a a chance on
YouTube to locate who it was that asked
it but somebody asked in one of the last
two sessions about what it means when I
say when people say that time is curved
right in the general theory of
relativity in special relativity - of
course we know that space and time are
all together they're blended into this
uniform continuum that we call
space-time so if we learn that space is
curved than the general theory of
relativity then we must know the time is
curved - but you know we all have an
image for what curved spaces but what
does curved time mean and the answer to
that is less mysterious than it sounds
it's not like you have a a Dali esque
like clock that sort of warp
time in some literal spatial way of
course a clock is warped in space it's
not itself warped in time but when we
say that time is warped we simply mean
that the rate at which time passes at
different locations need not be the same
and in particular what we learned in the
general theory of relativity is that if
you have a massive body that exerts the
force of gravity or curves the
environment around it the space-time
environment what that means is the
closer you get to that body
the slower clocks tick so if you had a
clock say that is at the top of the
Empire State Building
you have another clock on the ground
floor there at 34th and Fifth Avenue
would whatever the right address is I
think that's correct
then the clock at the top of the Empire
State Building will tick off time a
little more quickly than the clock at
the bottom of the Empire State Building
so time has warped in that sense you
know if you have a ruler that's worked
then different parts of the ruler will
measure different distances between the
same two locations right that's what a
warped non-uniform ruler would do if you
have time that's warped then clocks will
not measure the same elapsed time
between two events by virtue of this
warped or curved nature of time now for
the example of the Empire State Building
you'd say well why don't I know about
that the reason of course you all
absolutely already know as well the
amount of time warpage time curvature
between the top and the bottom of the
Empire State Building is tiny tiny tiny
fraction of a second we just don't
notice it but if you took that same
example and you put the Empire State
Building at the edge of a black hole
then the clock near the edge of the
black hole closer to the source of
gravity would tick off time far more
slowly than the clock farther away and
that would imprint be a measurable time
difference try to think of as mentioned
before in interstellar you saw that
example
directly as the astronauts that went
down to the planet that was closer to
the black hole than the crew member who
stayed up in the ship they just spent a
couple hours in that environment but
time is ticking off so slowly for them
so quickly compared to the clock on the
mothership that when they returned to
the ship their fellow crew member had
aged like 20 years where they had only
aged a couple of hours so that's what we
mean by curved time all right
moving onward what else do we have here
so salim yogi says dr. green thank you
for amazing words is it scientifically
correct to say that gravity is due to a
field property of space-time or is it
just pure objective geometric property
of space-time and it is a very it's a
very good question because we physicists
freely go back and forth between the
language of a gravitational field and
the language of the geometry of
space-time and I would encourage you to
feel comfortable going back and forth
between those languages as well in fact
you should feel comfortable using the
standard Newtonian language as well
where you talk about a force of gravity
one object pulling on another because
depending on the problem at hand one or
another language can give you the
greatest insight Einstein's general
theory of relativity language is indeed
one in which we think about gravity as
nothing but the curvature of space-time
so why do objects move in interesting
trajectories under the old Newtonian
language of the force of gravity
Einstein's answer they move in these
interesting trajectories these orbits
because they are sliding along these
grooves these indentations these valleys
in the geometrical structure of
space-time so there's a sentence where I
used the Newtonian gravitational force
language which is also the Newtonian
gravitational field language and also
the Einsteinian
geometrical language for the shape of
space-time and so freely move in between
those languages as befits whatever
situation you are in now let me just
give one example and I'm gonna in your
daily equation of next week
boy it is really windy here I don't know
if you guys can hear this but in a
moment I made me to close down the
windows even though it's quite hot in
here but next week in your daily
equation I'll make this point as well in
the Newtonian description right the
apocryphal or perhaps real story has it
that this apple fell from the tree and
it hit Newton in the head and the
Einstein game description in terms of
the geometry of space-time is actually
quite different because the freely
falling objects in Einstein's view they
are the ones that set the standard of
rest and therefore in an Einstein in
description the Apple when it's in
freefall after it detaches from the
branch it's just sort of hovering there
in space-time and it's Newton's head
that comes up and slams into the Apple
because Newton is not in a freely
falling frame sitting on the surface of
the earth the Earth's surface is getting
in the way of Newton's freefall Newton
can't fall through the rock of the
surface of the earth even though his
body would like to so that actually
helps us understand the ancient puzzle
that you all know the answer to but you
know why is it that two different
objects fall at the same rate regardless
of their mass I could try to do this but
I'll make a mess of it so a bit or not
but you know what I mean you take two
objects you know I don't want to break
the Apple pencil then I won't be able to
do your daily equation but you know I
let them go and they both fall together
why is that according to Newton it's
because there's equality between
gravitational mass and inertial mass
which means they both cancel out of the
F equals MA equation when the force is
equal to M over R squared times G that's
equal to M times a the ends on both
sides cancel so it's only the big mass
of the earth that really determines the
acceleration of each of these objects
they predict fall together but that's a
mystery why is gravity
facial mass equal to inertial mass
Einsteins answer is completely different
Einstein says when you let go of these
two objects I'm not gonna do it again
but when you let go of them they're in
freefall from your perspective which
Einstein says sets the standard of rest
now imagine therefore that they are at
rest in space-time and it's the earth
that's rushing up to them so why do they
hit the earth at the same moment
Einstein's answer is very
straightforward they hit the earth at
the same moment because they don't move
it's just the earth that comes up and
meets them and the earth has a singular
body when it moves up to their location
and hits them and of course it hits them
at the same moment they were just
sitting there waiting for the Earth's
arrival so that's the geometrical
einsteinium view and in that case it
does give us insight that otherwise
would be hard to glean okay so what else
do we have
alena says big fan of your videos thank
you Alena I appreciate that um
Abu Bakar Faruk we greetings professor
green watching you from Pakistan wow
that's great to hear
what is your view regarding the idea
that the entire universe is inside a
black hole well it's an interesting
question first of all talking about the
entire universe inside a black hole is a
bit extreme but but what I would say is
it is possible that at least according
to the traditional general relativistic
description of black holes I'm not going
to modify it with modern or more recent
conjectures speculations about firewalls
and all that sort of good stuff so let's
just act as though Einstein had the
important word on black holes which may
not be the case but if that's the if
that's true then right now it's quite
conceivable that the earth just passed
across the edge of a black hole that we
are all now inside of a black hole why
is that the edge of a black hole in
Einstein's description is not some
special location in space it's just an
ordinary chunk of space that has the
usual property that once you pass that
location the event horizon you are no
longer able to get out but you don't
have any direct physical reaction to
crossing over the event horizon of a
black hole and so right now
everything you know as we look around
the world we could all be within a black
hole and will only really recognize that
later on when we get closer and closer
to the center of the black hole because
then depending on our precise distance
from the black hole different parts of
the earth different parts of our body
will feel a different force if we are
going feet first toward the center of a
black hole our feet will experience a
greater pull than our head our body will
be stretched spaghettified is the
technical term that we use for this
process until ultimately we're pulled
apart into our constituent particles
that will all rain down on the
singularity whatever that is the center
of the black hole we don't really
understand what goes on there so in that
sense we could all be within a black
hole right now I'm not exactly sure how
to describe that if you want to truly
think of the entire universe but you
know any large chunk of the universe
could follow exactly the same process
that I just described for the earth and
therefore in that sense we could be
within a black hole um Nikhil Taha
Lonnie says hello professor iam a
computer science student in India boy a
lot of Pakistan India - it's fantastic
recently developed interest in physics
because of you oh that's great to hear
it really is great to hear it's so
inspiring to hear that you know these
little videos that that I created in
this little room here other things that
we do actually reach out and and affect
people so thank you for telling me about
that question is can you guide me if I
can do both together namely computer
science and physics and where I should
start and the answer is out absolutely
number one the distinctions between
computer science and physics have
certainly
been blurred in in the last few years in
a substantial way because one of the
dominant interesting problems that
people who have been focusing their
attention on quantum mechanics for a
long time that they're focusing on is
quantum computing now to really see
whether we can inject our understanding
of quantum physics into a new kind of
computational procedure now look of
course every computer in some sense is a
quantum computer because the integrated
circuit only exists because we can
manipulate the motion of tiny particles
like electrons and we need quantum
mechanics to understand how to do that
but quantum computing picks that into a
radically different direction not just
the technological innards of a computer
to be governed by quantum physics but
rather the computational process itself
making use of the full might the full
power of quantum mechanics roughly
speaking if you buy into the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics it's
as if we're trying to build computers
that will do parallel processing of
certain kinds of computational
procedures across the many universes
that quantum reality spans make use of
all of those universes to simultaneously
crack apart various parts of an
interesting calculation at the end find
a matter of pulling out the solution
that we are looking for from this broad
swath of parallel computational
procedures so I don't know if that kind
of blending of physics and computer
science fires you up to kill but that
certainly is an arena in which you would
be well posed to make a contribution by
carrying on with your studies in
computer science but also building up
your understanding of physics with all
the standard things classical mechanics
quantum mechanics thermodynamics you
need all of that and some of that you
can learn on your own so I would look at
you know wherever you are the course of
study that's available to see about
blending these but it's not as though
you're saying to me you know I want to I
want to
dance in the Bolshoi Ballet and I also
want to be the next Einstein not
impossible and I would actually I would
actually encourage you if if that was
your dream but what you're saying is
easily more easily attainable than that
particular goal that particular dream
because computer science and physics are
are no longer as far apart as perhaps
your studies might suggest that they are
ok what else do we have
there's an interesting question here oh
here's one from China you ping Jiang hi
professor a big fan from China thank you
you ping if I move close to the speed of
light relative to you but from my
perspective you are the one who is
moving fast so in the end who is getting
older and yeah you ping that is a puzzle
it is one that people have kicked around
for a long time
we think we understand it quite well
which is that the notion of Hugh who is
getting older is a question that needs
to be framed with greater precision in
order to really answer your question and
the real question is if you and I get
back together and we compare our ages
either visibly or more precisely with
our watches on whose watch will more
time have elapsed and if it's the case
that I say I'm not experiencing any say
acceleration during this entire journey
right this entire journey I'm just sort
of sitting around and I never feel a
force on my body I never feel a change
in my speed but you in order to come
back to me must feel that change let's
say you go out in space you've got to
turn around and come back that
turnaround is an acceleration you will
feel it it is a change in your velocity
a change in the speed and direction of
your motion and that's what breaks the
symmetry that otherwise would be quite
confusing and because of that break and
symmetry you feel the acceleration but I
do not then it turns out that you can
establish
that you are the one that is going to be
younger on the return I will be the one
who is old it is your watch that would
be ticking off time more slowly now you
might say that feels like we're relying
too much on acceleration to address the
issue and indeed there are other
versions of the story you could go out
into space and rather than literally you
turn around imagine that you've worked
out with a friend of the or as a partner
in crime that they are heading toward me
and they set out on the journey in just
the right way that you and your friend
pass each other and you're able to hand
off your watch to your friend and your
friend brings that watch back here so no
one's accelerated in this case you never
turned around you came back your friend
didn't accelerate they were always
traveling toward me what happens in that
circumstance and the answer is a little
bit different during the handoff between
you and your friend that is a change in
frame of reference which actually
changes your perspective on what events
are happening simultaneously at the same
moment if you take that into account
there's a jump in time between what your
friend what you said was happening at
the same moment and what your friend
says is happening at the same moment and
that also comes in the exact same
conclusion if you want to see this done
fully and visually obviously there's
just so much I can do in explaining
things on the fly right here but I have
a whole course on the special theory of
relativity there's a math version of it
there's a visual version of it you can
look at these courses take these courses
for free at world science u.com that
website is being relaunched refreshed I
think it's still available right now but
if it's not within a week or two it will
be available and toward the end of that
course they're like 44 modules a lot of
content in there but I show you visually
what it would look like in sort of any
scenario of the twin paradox that would
come to mind and so the short answer is
I will be the one who is older if I
didn't accelerate the long answer is go
check out all the detail
unreal sign - I think I think you would
enjoy doing that and that goes for any
of you who want to see special
relativity done in a highly visual as
well as mathematical way okay what do we
have here
hello sir a seat - says you were my
inspiration thank you how is how in
string theory is it that vibrations give
rise to new kinds of particles and yeah
that is the basic idea in string theory
and let me just explain the essence of
it
so in string theory we imagine at least
in the most vanilla bread and butter
approach to string theory people gone in
many different directions with these
ideas let me just give you the the
dominant way that people have thought
about things for a long time if you were
to take an elementary particle like an
electron or a cork and somehow we're
able to magnify it to an extent that you
could see its most deep inner structure
you'd find that each of those particles
is composed of a vibrating filament a
one-dimensional vibrating filament and
you might say how could particles as
different as an electron the cork
they've got different electric charges
they respond to the strong nuclear force
in different ways how is it that a
string can distinguish them and and
here's the idea and I'll focus on mass
is that's the easiest example easiest
quality for me to talk about the mass of
a particle in string theory comes from
its energy right Einstein taught us e
equals MC squared the most famous of all
equations the equation I started with a
month ago in this series of your daily
equation let's turn that equation around
actually turn it around in the way that
einstein himself wrote it in his
September 1905 paper he didn't write
equals MC squared back these different
symbols but put back to the side instead
he wrote M equals E over C squared M
equals E over C squared so mass comes
from energy divided by C squared so if
you want to know the mass of a part of
that emerges from a vibrating string you
find the energy of the vibrating string
divide it by C squared so how do you get
two particles of different masses you
get two particles of different masses by
having two strings vibrating with
different energies one is vibrating
slowly if I can use ordinary language
one is vibrating more vigorously faster
greater energy greater mass so that's C
that's the way that the one and the same
ingredient the same vibrating filament
is not like you've got different
filaments of the same species of
filament but if they vibrate in
different ways
you get different masses now to describe
different electric charges is a little
bit more subtle that would take me
pretty far afield but it's qualitatively
no different from that it's just there
are more exotic qualities of a vibrating
string that correspond to charge and if
it's vibrating in one manner in those
qualities that will yield one charge
vibrating differently will yield a
different charge okay what do we have
here
Ali unis cyan as how should we study to
be a good physicist please specify brian
is very important to make sure look the
most important thing if you're asking me
when you're in the learning phase of
physics is that you don't get distracted
by things that are happening at the
frontier of research and think that you
can jump right to the edge of
understanding without slogging through
all of the basic foundational material I
can't tell you the number of students
that come to me and they just say hey
I'm I'm ready I just want to work on
string theory I want to work on black
holes or I want to work on the Big Bang
I mean it's exciting for me to hear the
interest in working on those subjects
but the fact of the matter is if you
don't understand classical mechanics and
quantum mechanics and differential
equations and thermodynamics and
statistical mechanics and special
relativity and general tivity and
quantum field theory and on it goes the
traditional
graduate and graduate curriculum if you
don't have that solidly under your belt
it's gonna be very hard for you to
contribute so although it may feel that
that materials old and you don't really
need to know that material the fact of
the matter is physics is a very
hierarchical vertical subject the things
that we work on today rest upon the
things that we learned yesterday and by
yesterday I mean everything from truly
yesterday back to a few centuries ago so
the answer is you just need to work day
and night to learn the basic material
and it's not just a matter of reading it
it's a matter of doing problems and
problems you need to gain a facility
with putting the material into action so
it's a lot of hard work but the payoff
is significant number one you understand
the materials so much better when you
work through it every equation you
understand every problem in the book you
can solve but it then prepares you for
bringing all that knowledge to bear on
cutting-edge research and that's really
the way to get there there's there's no
shortcut unfortunately göran kohler asks
how do you balance life and work well
you should ask my wife and kids not well
all the time sometimes I do it better
than others but I kind of work all the
time I kind of work seven days a week I
don't come to Saturday and Sunday and
say oh it's over I don't have to think
about things until Monday and you know
my family has come to accept that
perhaps the reason is my wife and I both
are the the folks who started this world
Science Festival which is the rubric
under which this your daily equation and
many are the things sits so because we
work together on this it doesn't always
feel as though I am leaving the family
conversation if I'm working on things in
least in this regard my kids get a
little bit tired of the fact that my
wife and I both work a lot all the time
so yes the balance is not is not always
there but I certainly have found the
ability more now than say 20 years ago
to pull away from either doing a physics
research project or writing a book or
doing this kind of an activity to spend
more time with kids and I have to tell
you it's the most important the most
vital thing to do and this pandemic only
brings a home even further in the end
what really matters what really matters
are the people you spend time with and
the people that you affect and the
relationships that you have because in
the end everything just evaporates into
the void that doesn't mean it's not
important to strive it's not important
to understand the universe I'm driven to
do that but in the end what really
matters are are the relationships and
it's hard to keep that in mind but it's
it's vital to do so all right what do we
have here
cosmic slice I'm going to miss the World
Science Festival this year I love
volunteering at it yes I agree you know
we're going to do a kind of World
Science Festival this year we're not
going to do it like all at once in a
five-day period as we do when it's a
live event we will roll out a series of
programs over the coming months some of
those programs we're going to will take
place right in this space right here
others we have other ideas up our
sleeves for what they will look like but
from that perspective unfortunately
volunteering is not something that is
relevant with the way the world is at
the moment but the program's themselves
they will be coming so at least that
side of it
will carry forward professor green
Divya Raj asks what to do when your
school intervals interferes in your
education that is an encapsulation of a
quote of the man himself Albert Einstein
and I appreciate that reference Einstein
said the only thing that interferes in
his learning was his education you know
but Einstein was Einstein Einstein was
the kind of guy who could go off and
read the Great's of physics you know
read it read Maxwell's original works
Keir cough Reid Lorentz you know Reid
plank and and not only digest what they
were talking about but be able to take
their ideas to the next level
unfortunately most of us are not
Einstein what I'd love to be at the
level of an Einstein yeah I really would
how exciting to be able to revolution
our understanding of things but you come
to terms with the limited capacities
that you have in any domain and for most
of us that limited capacity means we do
have to be educated most of us cannot
just do the Einstein thing or do the
Ramanuja thing where we can just learn
on our own you know that would be great
if we could and if it works for you
fantastic but for most of us the
education process doesn't interfere with
our learning it's part of the learning I
hope you guys are not distracted by my
dog who seems to be barking outside the
window that probably is because my dog
Luna has a different perspective on
learning and education and understanding
it wants to chime in but you know Luna
you want to say something get your own
damn show this is my show okay so I'm
just gonna say my view I'm learning in
education no Luna if you have anything
you want to say feel free to chime in
again and I'll try to interpret for the
audience
okay so Muhammad Xun a ho asked dr.
Brian in thermodynamics we have
something called a closed system in
which only energy can be exchanged not
matter isn't it against mass energy
equivalence
well the the usual way that we do
thermodynamics and I hope I'm
interpreting your question correctly if
not feel free to ask it again if I
misinterpreted it in in thermodynamics
there are two ways in which we formulate
the theory when we apply the equations
to a close to system we really mean that
it's really close in the sense that it's
not interacting with the environment
around it all the stuff all the energy
all the mass it's all staying within
that environment the alternative is when
we look at an open system and an open
system
freely can't exchange things with the
environment now you're right in certain
circumstances we only allow certain
qualities to be exchanged but the real
reason why we distinguish you being a
closed system and an open system is for
a closed system we can argue that the
entropy will not never go down but is
highly highly unlikely to go down
whereas for an open system entropy can
leave it can be expelled with the stuff
that you are allowing to cross the
border the open border if you will and
therefore an open system and to be can
go down and of course when I look at
myself I am an open system in the sense
that I'm constantly emitted emitting
entropy to the surroundings heat waste
going outward and that allows my entropy
to not continually increase which would
not be good for my health so the way I
keep my health the way I keep myself
intact is through my interactions with
the environment allowing myself to be an
open not a closed system and that
openness is what allows my entropy to
seemingly thwart the second law of
thermodynamics but of course it doesn't
because if you take account of the
entropy that I released the environment
then with that contribution the overall
entropy of me and the surroundings does
go up okay what else do we have here
there's an entanglement that just went
by me and I missed it here it is
Oh Priya - why are particles entangled
just by interacting and it's not enough
that particles interact - to have the
kind of entanglement that for instance I
used in your daily equation in
describing entangled that was for called
maximal entanglement where I had these
two particles one is spinning up and one
was spinning down you remember how that
goes and and that state of affairs will
not generally be in force
by simply two particles interacting the
way you get those kinds of entangled
particles is for instance you take like
one example is you take a calcium atom
and you excite the calcium atom maybe
you shine some laser light on it as the
calcium atom falls back down to the less
excited state it releases energy in the
form of photons and one way that it can
release that energy is giving off
back-to-back photons and those
back-to-back photons will be analogous
to the spin-up and spin-down electrons
they will be maximally entangled they
will have an overall zero angular
momentum state even though each of them
can have some spin angular momentum and
those spins will be correlated in such a
way that they mimic what I was
describing with the entangle electrons
so in that case it's not that the the
photons interacted to become maximally
entangled rather the calcium atom is the
unique common starting point and when it
reduces to its less excited state it
emits these particles it creates these
particles in this maximally entangled
state Titan says god I love science
that's an interesting sentence I love
that god I love science I'm not sure how
to to fully interpret it but it seems to
have a good feel to it let's see what do
we have here a su Susan van de ham Susan
band ahem ah I got that aka primordial
soup do you think there really is an end
to smallness do I really think there's
an end to smallness so I gathered what
that question is you know the
progression of the history of science is
you got stuff macroscopic bulky stuff
you look at it sufficiently powerful
microscope or you dissect it you get two
molecules you get two atoms atoms you
get two electrons around the nucleus the
neutrons the proton
inside the neutrals approaches got the
quarks if string theory is right and we
don't know that it is you keep on going
you get to the string as a question is
does it keep on going or is there an end
and we don't know the answer to that my
guess is that there is an end I don't
see any reason why this chapter of
exploration needs to go on forever it
could well be that the universe truly
does have some fundamental indivisible
uncuttable elementary constituents do we
have those in hand it's possible that we
do already it's quite possible that we
do not however the motivation for
thinking that this journey will go on
forever is one of pattern the pattern is
that we have always found smaller stuff
inside of bigger stuff but I don't see
any fundamental reason why that pattern
will persist indefinitely so if you ask
me for my guess and it really is just a
guess
my guess is that there are fundamental
entities that will not admit a finer
level of structure and there are
fundamental laws that govern how those
fundamental entities behave now it's
interesting you know somebody the other
day challenged me on my use of govern in
a sentence like that do laws govern how
the particles behave or do the particles
just do what they want to do and we have
these mathematical laws that seem to be
pretty good at describing what they are
doing and you know what's my view on
that my my language certainly my
language is I tend to use the word
govern because I really do
as I said I really do think that even if
we don't have the fundamental laws in
hand my view is that the universe is
lawful it's an assumption but it's an
assumption that seems to resonate well
with everything that we have so far
discovered about reality that there are
laws and those laws are unbreakable and
if you have unbreakable laws it feels to
me it suggests to me it seems to me that
you are justified in thinking of those
laws as governing what happens because
the particles cannot simply do whatever
they want to do the particles only
execute behaviors that are compatible
with the fundamental governing laws so
so that's my in some sense view of the
fundamental nature of reality
fundamental nature of the world there
are some elementary things that can't be
divided further there are some
fundamental laws that are in control of
the behavior of those entities the
entities don't have a mind of their own
in the sense of they can say well the
fundamental law says X but I'm gonna do
Y first of all that sentence doesn't
really even make sense but more
importantly it's not compatible with our
understanding of how the particles that
we do have control over actually behave
so so yes the idea of laws governing
stuff is the view of reality that I
think is the right way of thinking about
things and I prove that no can anyone
prove otherwise you know the only data
suggest that that is the right way of
looking about things so it feels to me
like it's a reasonable way of describing
reality so fella super says hi Green
greetings from Norway doesn't quantum
entanglement break the principle and
special relativity that simultaneity is
relative it actually does not I
understand your thinking on that you
know if you have distant particles and
they're very far apart
and if you measure one and I say
instantaneously the other snaps out of
the haze of up and down I'm saying well
that's simultaneous but what I really
mean it's simultaneous from one
perspective from one frame of reference
let's imagine that these two particles
are not moving relative to me this frame
of reference that I am in then the
action that I'm talking about is
simultaneous in this frame but if if you
fellows super are moving relative to me
then you would tell a different story of
what happened if you're moving relative
to me in one direction you will say one
particle snapped out of the haze first
and then the other snapped out those
events would not be simultaneous for the
very reason that you said that
simultaneity is relative and if you're
moving in the other direction
you will say the other particle snap out
of the haze first and then the second
particle snapped out subsequently so
depending on your frame of reference
your description of what happens in the
measurement of an entangled pair will be
different the point that I'm making is
there is a frame of reference in which
they happen simultaneously and that
means and let me just stress this so
that it can be no confusion here you
might say well if one snaps out first
and then the other why can't we describe
it in terms of a signal from one to the
other but bear in mind that if you have
two particles snapping out
simultaneously their so-called space
like separated which means that even
though the events may appear to have a
chronology one happens before the other
depending on your frame of reference you
will never have a frame of reference in
which there's enough time between one
snapping out and the other for a signal
to travel between them so everybody and
his brother and his sister will agree
that there's no way that a signal could
go from one to the other to explain one
snapping out and then the other some
will say that they happen simultaneously
others will say that they don't happen
simultaneously but everyone will agree
that you can't explain it with a signal
traveling less than or equal to the
speed of light going from
after it snapped out alerting the other
and then it snaps out that explanation
everyone will agree that that
explanation fails okay so
Kella me neva says from a big fan in
Brazil well thank you I'm more than
happy if you just want to chime in with
comments you don't have to only ask
questions thank you
Boogaloo ball edge of the wedge theorem
asks what type of mathematics have you
used
but you where you were surprised that it
is helpful in this case well yeah you
know I give you one concrete example it
goes back a number of years but it was
among the most exciting years ago I was
working on properties of the extra
dimensions in string theory you know
that string theory requires six or seven
extra dimensions depending on how you
how you count how you describe it and I
became interested with a couple of
colleagues David Morrison and Paul
Aspinwall on whether the fabric of space
might be able to rip to tear and to
address this question we found that we
had to invoke some fairly esoteric
mathematics from algebraic geometry and
from a fairly esoteric at least to me at
the time way of representing geometrical
surfaces that that naturally emerge from
algebraic geometry and with that
description we were able to get a sharp
mathematical understanding of the fabric
of space and were able to show that it
can actually rip apart you may have read
about this if you've looked at the
elegant universe in I think it's chapter
11 or 10 or something like that it's too
long ago now by the way I'm actually
planning on coming out with a new
version of the elegant universe for the
one or two of you who may have read that
book and it's going to have an update
I'm not going to change the chapters
that exist but I'm going to update the
book bring it right up to the present so
for the 25th anniversary which is in
2024 it's hard to believe is 25 years
ago but for the 25th anniversary edition
of that book I'm going to add some
chapters so you can
catch up on things that you might have
read elsewhere which would be kind of
fun but that's the answer to your
question Boogaloo both edge of the wedge
theorem that was an example where some
pretty high-powered math and algebraic
geometry turned out to be the right
language for discussing the ripping of
space campus cryptid writes hell yeah
I'm not sure what Hellyeah refers to but
hopefully it was something that I said
that you were so excited about that you
removed to to write that let's see what
we have here is well I'm gonna go to
this other list from Twitter for just
half a second just so I mix it up a
little bit what do we have here
Nikita geico asks tell me if I'm wrong
that most of the current mass and energy
in the universe was condensed from the
in photon field after a tremendous
expansion so the total energy of the
universe increased does this break the
first law of thermodynamics of energy
conservation and you're not mistaken
Nikita in your description so let me
just even put some numbers into the
inflationary theory the inflationary
theory shows that you can have a little
tiny region of space roughly say 10 to
the minus 26 10 to the minus 27 meters
across so it's really tiny it can be
filled with you know roughly uh a few
ounces or a couple pounds worth of in
photon or maybe I should talk about
kilograms for this international
audience so it could be filled with a vo
grams or kilograms worth of the in
photon field so not a lot there and as
it swells from me for a pulse of push of
the in photon field that region of space
swells enormous Li as it swells the in
photon field continues to fill that
region of space so you may have begun
with say kilogram of M photon field but
if the size of the space grows by a huge
factor then the amount of in photon
field filling it also grows by a huge
factor so then you might say well
where does the energy come from because
now you've got more because the region
of space is incomparably larger and the
answer that we typically give to that
well there are two answers you could
give one answer that's not really
satisfying that you give is that the
conservation of energy has to be
carefully thought through when you apply
it to the universe as a whole and
whereas you can have local energy
conservation turning it into a global
statement can be challenging if you
looked at the episode on no--there's
theorem that we had and unless people
looked at the episode unnotice theorem
which makes me think that you actually
overall don't really like the technical
mathematical equations as much as you do
the discussion of the big idea so tell
me if you disagree with that because my
temptation is to do more of the big
ideas if it appeals to more of you but
that's a sidelight in that episode in
your daily equation I showed how you get
global conservation laws from symmetry
but that was applied to a system within
the universe if you look at the universe
as a whole and you think through the
steps there's some subtleties that don't
always go through depending on the
precise shape the topology the geometry
of the universe but anyway I didn't
think that answer would be particularly
satisfying so I just put that out there
as an interesting point the dancer that
I think you'll like better Nikita is the
following you may recall that gravity
can have and typically does have
negative energy remember when you
learned about gravitational potential
energy in physics 1 what is the
gravitational potential energy it goes
like minus GM over R right if you have a
mass M and that's a negative in front so
when R goes to infinity say a little
test particle would have zero potential
energy but as it comes in it's in a
gravitational field giving rise to a
negative potential minus GMM over R
second and the little guy over R the
importance of that is the following
a negative number I mean it can go
arbitrarily negative so as the in photon
field as its energy is going up and up
and up filling more and more space the
gravitational potential energy is going
down and down ever more negative so
there's a balancing that can happen
there so it may look like there's more
energy because this space is bigger and
it's filled with the M photon field but
if you account for the negative
potential energy of gravity becoming
ever more negative they cancel each
other out allowing a kind of energy
conservation still to hold so that I
think is a more satisfying answer Makita
if you're actually watching the live
chime in on the live feed and I can get
a sense of whether that addressed your
question let me go back to the live
YouTube chat and see what else we have
here
let's see let's see what we got here car
Braun's asks about quantum biology and
expresses some skepticism saying I
smelled something funny but with a with
a smiley face and no quantum biology is
a real serious and significant field you
know mostly we think about quantum
mechanics is being confined to
individual atoms and molecules and
things that are pretty small but
remarkably scientists have found that
there are certain quantum processes that
take place in certain biological systems
that have a macroscopic manifestation I
don't remember the details we did a
program on this in the World Science
Vessel so if you're interested just
search world Science Vessel quantum
biology but there are certain navigation
systems in birds I believe in which
scientists have traced the birds ability
to navigate on certain trajectories to
certain quantum interactions between
molecules in their brain and say the
magnetic field of the earth or things of
that sort so quantum biology is hugely
exciting because
it suggests that nature has found clever
ways of leveraging some of the
spectacular qualities of quantum physics
into adaptive processes adaptive
behaviors and now first thought you say
well why wouldn't nature do that quantum
physics is real quantum physics affects
how particles behave and if a species
comes along and by chance finds a means
of tapping into those quantum processes
more directly than we would have thought
based upon you know everyday experience
with magnets at macroscopic things in
the world around us and if there really
was adaptive value to it then that
species would have a better chance of
having progeny and passing on to the
next generation that very same ability
to leverage quantum physics so I don't
think it smells funny at all it smells
kind of sweet and exciting so from that
perspective it really is an exciting
development to see quantum physics
manifests in biological systems okay
what do we have here back to this feed
here so you Flo says professor green my
name is Eugene and here's my question
can a clock be defined in a different
way than a cyclical motion device atomic
clocks of course are a cyclical motion
device and I'm always reluctant to say
no because there's always some clever
thing that you can come along with but
it's hard for me to fully understand
what a clock would be if in some way
shape or form it wasn't relying in some
kind of cyclical process because what we
do to talk about the passage of time is
we count the number of processes that go
by between the beginning the start of
the event and the end of the event so we
want a cyclical process and we want to
be stable cyclical process so we can say
hey
it took ten of those processes for
so-and-so to drink that glass of water
or it took fifty nine of those cyclical
processes for so-and-so to solve that
math problem now we often call those
cyclical processes by seconds if we
tuned them in the right way but it's
hard for me to really understand what we
would mean by the passage of time in
terms of a quantitative measure if we
didn't have some kind of cyclical
process that was stable so he could
depend upon the cycles being identical
thereby lasting the same duration so
look no doubt there's something that
someone's going to come back to me on
with that but it's pretty profoundly
woven into our thinking about time that
we measure it with a device that has
some cyclical process embedded within it
okay okay what else do we have here
dhama dark posad s asks is there a
possibility for math to be different in
a multiverse if it exists and sure look
it depends on how how you interpret
mathematics but actually based on either
interpretation there is a version of
your question that I would answer in the
affirmative so one way of interpreting
your question is this math twosome is
nothing but a language it's a human
invented language just like English just
like Hindi just like Swedish whatever
these are all just languages that
emerged by virtue of the human brain
finding it useful to codify certain
patterns in natural language the
patterns that we codify are the typical
things that we encounter in daily life
day to day life in mathematics the kinds
of things that we quantify are more
specific to particular processes that
happen in the world you know you bring
two coconuts - your friend someone else
has one coconut you put the
you got three coconuts there's a pattern
there and of course we take those
patterns as the brain matures and
refines and describe ever more esoteric
patterns less and less available to
everyday experience but if you believe
as some do that whether it's natural
language or mathematics it is simply a
human invented construct language then
of course if there's a multiverse it's
possible that other members in other
universes will have different
mathematics in fact you don't have to go
to a multiverse it could be another
planets forget about the multiverse and
other planets those living systems they
may have codified patterns in a
different way or they may have found
that the kinds of patterns that we find
to be useful the seasonal motion of the
planets around the Sun helps us know
when to plant crops if on that other
world maybe they live beneath the
surface they don't see the Sun or a star
the notion of orbiting and orbital
periods just has no pull no value in
their culture the mathematics that they
come up with may be quite different from
the mathematics that we come up with
maybe it's not even mathematics at all
maybe it's a whole different kind of way
of engaging with the world and
mathematics may not be anything that
they've ever invented or paid attention
to now to contrast that there are some
people think that mathematics is not
invented it's not a language mathematics
is just truly stitched within the fibers
of reality and we physical beings are
nothing but an incarnation of the
underlying mathematical equations that
goes even further than anything that I
really feel comfortable espousing I'm
not ready to say that math is so
fundamental that any mathematical
equation is relevant to the physical
world
there are some who do if you want to
read about them at for next tegmark has
a whole book on that I
think it goes a little too far for my
taste but if that were the case then you
might say could other places have
different mathematics well they could
have found different mathematics than we
have found but it's all part of one
grand collection of ideas that we call
mathematics and we may have found one
little island of that territory of math
others may find other islands but we
would all be part of the same
overarching fundamental structure the
mathematical reality that this
perspective puts forward so two views
each come to the conclusion that when we
talk to the aliens their math may be
different from ours every reason suspect
that in fact it might be see of s72 men
as how big is the unobservable universe
well good the observable universe has a
finite size it's simply how far away
objects can now be and yet their light
would have had time say since the Big
Bang to traverse our separation and
reach our telescopes or reach our eyes
and that number is about 45 billion
light years in each and every direction
beyond that is the unobservable or the
yet to be observed depending on how the
universe expands universe how far does
the unobserved part of the universe go
on the answer is we don't know it could
go on forever it could be infinite space
might go on infinitely far which is so
easy to say and so difficult to really
understand infinitely far it never stops
like where did that come from who
provided that amount of real estate I
mean these kinds of questions come to
mind because we live in a finite
environment everything may encounter is
finite it's so hard to wrap your mind
around something that is truly infinite
and who knows maybe it's not truly
infinite it's a possibility but nobody
knows for sure it could be that you
travel out into space officially far and
you hit a wall
maybe there really is an end out there
and that's not so crazy there's a
version of string theory in which you
imagine the extra dimensions have a
particular shape and one shape that
people have discussed amounts to having
to brick walls on either ends of this
universe they might say what's on the
other side empty space no nothing no
reality is on the other side it's hard
to picture everything that has a border
right I mean this box you know my my air
pots this box it has a border and
outside the border there's more space
but imagine that the border of the
universe is the end of reality not
emptiness not space that's yet to be
inhabited nothing beyond the end that's
a possibility - or it could be this face
wraps in on itself right you know and I
have my basketball here any longer but
you know it could be that space is
curved you go out in space in one
direction you go far enough and
ultimately without even turning around
you wind up returning to your starting
point from behind your initial location
that's what happens on planet Earth if I
walk out in that direction I go far
enough I will circle around I'll
circumnavigate the earth you perhaps
conservative circles
the right shape which would mean that
it's finite it does not go on forever
and yet there's no wall that you
encounter it's simply the shape allows
it to have the property of finiteness
without an edge without a boundary so
yeah it's a great question it's a tough
one that's the current state of the art
understanding Christopher asked dr.
Greene which is your favorite my
favorite what Christopher you must have
been referring to something I said at
that moment but I have no idea so Chris
if you want to chime back in I'd be
happy to tell you what my favorite is
but without any noun there it's hard for
me to answer ah little big von Beethoven
is back so good to see you again Ludwig
von Beethoven it's the name that always
sticks with me because I am a great fan
of the Ludwig von Beethoven but anyone
who has his name I assume as a fan as
well oh I see
confirm the World Science Festival is
sponsored by Apple
we're not sponsored by Apple I'd be
happy if we were sponsored by Apple I'd
happily take their support to create all
sorts of cool content so if you guys
want to lobby Apple to support us I'd be
all too happy but when I pick up any of
my gear is simply because it is around
me there is zero product placement there
is ZERO monetization happening on any of
the stuff that we are doing this is all
just to bring these ideas out there no
motivation beyond that ok I've been told
by Siavash that I butchered the name
sorry and there's no way maybe you could
spell it out phonetically for me next
time and do my best
okay so we have rygg I asked dr. Greene
can you go into more about the
difference between the 50% chance of
spin with quantum entanglement right
versus the 55% theorized by Einstein
where did the 5% go ah good question
good question so remember how this went
actually I don't have to take a sip of
water
is this this question is good it's gonna
take me a moment to answer so remember
I'm Stein's perspective he says he says
come on quantum mechanics people can you
really believe that if you have two
widely separated objects each in a fuzzy
statistical mixture going up and down
that if you measure one that it can have
an impact on the other arbitrarily far
apart arbitrarily distant from the first
he says come on you can't
stably believe that and he says I've got
a better way of explaining what's really
going on here
Einstein says look your quantum math
says this particle is in a fuzzy mixture
50% up 50% down but that's not what's
really going on that's merely a
limitation of the quantum mathematics to
describe the true reality if you measure
that particle and you find it up it
always was up the math might have said
it was doing this but it wasn't really
doing that at all it's a limitation of
your knowledge of reality it was up all
the time when you measured it you simply
found what was already there similarly
if this one you measure it you find it
down it was always down so there's no
spooky action because when you measure
this one and find it up it was up when
you measure this one you find it down it
was down from the get-go always were in
this complementary pair of up and down
john bell comes along and says well
Einstein couldn't talk to him directly
by this point Einstein had passed away
but Bell in essence says well Einstein
that's an interesting suggestion the
particles always have these definite
features even though quantum mechanics
is saying that they don't is there a
consequence of that at first sight
people thought no remember I think I
mentioned that Wolfgang Pauli attributed
the way of thinking about the world to
being no better than trying to count
angels dancing on the head of the pen
it's as if I again the example I use
with you guys we use it again it's as if
I say to you hey guys my hair color is
actually in a fuzzy mixture of pink and
blue when you're not looking but when
you look it snaps to one definite gray
or white whatever the right description
of my hair color may be how can you ever
test that was in a mixture without
measuring but everybody says once you
measure you find a definite result so it
seems like it's untestable now to your
question about the 55% reigai re guy
john bell
shows that if you are measuring the
particles in a more clever way not just
along one spin axis but along three spin
axes he finds that there is a measurable
consequence to Einstein's perspective
that the particles have a definite spin
when you're not actually even measuring
them he finds that these detectors if
you do random measurements of the
particles on a great many runs of the
experiment they should disagree the
particle should be up and down at least
55 percent of the time that's a
consequence of Einstein's vision that
there's no spooky action and that
therefore particles have definite
features that's testable you do the
experiment and you don't get you don't
get Einsteins prediction you find 50% of
the time they are found to be in these
oppositely oriented pairs so where did
the 5 percent go it was not ever there
Einstein's prediction was wrong Einstein
didn't even know it made a prediction it
took John Bell to figure that out but in
essence Einsteins vision of the world
no spookiness and therefore definite
features is ruled out what does that
mean well Einsteins vision no spookiness
there for definite features that's wrong
therefore there is spookiness there can
be spookiness and definite features but
there has to be long-range connection in
this way of thinking about things that's
the answer the 5% was an incorrect
prediction the 55% therefore was an
incorrect prediction 50% is the right
prediction and it's the quantum
mechanical prediction all right I hope
that clarifies there where I got asked
again it's I didn't convince you of that
so what else do we have should I look
maybe on a on a Twitter thingy what do
we have over here hemant streak ass
hello sir can you help us imagine non
Euclidean geometry of space-time
very hard I can help you understand
non-euclidean geometry of space but I
know that's not what you're asking
nan you could add geometry space is just
non flat surfaces that's the
2-dimensional version and the surface of
a basketball is a really good example of
a non Euclidean a sense of non flat
surface but to bring time into the story
it's harder to picture mentally you know
the there the diagnostic that I gave in
the last your daily equation is I wonder
if I can even bring my iPad up just to
remind you of the diagnostic I'm gonna
try to do this I hope I don't cut
everybody off so did that work am I on
this thing here mmm-hmm I'm trying to
share my screen with you guys let's see
if this works if it doesn't work then
I'll go back to just describing things
in words but I think this is going to
work and let me bring up a notability
thingy here so hopefully that's working
with us right now and you may recall
that I gave you a diagnostic for when a
shape is curved and the diagnostic is
you take a vector at some location in
that space and what you do is you move
that vector around so I'm gonna do that
here I'm gonna take a copy of this guy
put them over here paste it and now I'm
gonna move it and notice as I move this
vector around on the plane regardless of
what path I follow when I get back to my
starting point the new vector is
pointing in exactly the same direction
as the original vector on a curved
surface like a basketball in fact I used
a basketball last time and I was
describing it that will not be the case
you don't return to your starting point
the vector instead points in a different
direction why don't I bring that up I
bring it up because imagine you're in
space time and in space time you can
carry various things around you can for
instance carry around a clock and as you
carry around this clock the
when you return to your starting point
will the reading on your clock agree
with the clock that stayed at your
starting location and the answer to that
in general for a curved space-time will
be no as you Paulo transported around in
the language of the field if not it does
not return to its original configuration
so curvature for a basketball that makes
sense
curvature of space-time harder to
envision but it's the same kind of
diagnostic tool fundamentally it's the
same mathematics all right
eric w asks you mentioned working all
the time no interesting hobbies well
over time I've sort of found that my
hobbies have integrated inserted
themselves in my work in a sense you
know I I'm a great fan I love music I
love the arts my dad was a vocal coach a
bass player a musician a composer and so
I grew up in a household that was filled
with that kind of an artistic
environment and so for a good fraction
of my life that was sort of a hobby ask
part of what I do but you may have seen
I've mentioned it before that with world
science festival we've been blending art
and science in particular projects that
I've been involved with have blended
music blended staged blended physics all
in sort of one interesting unified
package another project that we're
working on right now is this story I
wrote about a boy going to the edge of a
black hole
Icarus at the edge of time which we
collaborated with the composer Philip
Glass to create a live stage
presentation where we have a sequel to
that that will be coming out you know as
soon as the world gets back to normal if
that ever happens so again that's a
blending of my own interest in music and
stage presentation together with the
bread and butter of my professional
career which is physics and calculations
and things of that sort so I'd say over
time the things that I do have become
so enmeshed with one another that I
don't even consider a distinction
between what's a hobby and what I do
they've all kind of blended together
into into one one whole alright what
else do we have here
Gesell Jessel vara one says what's the
biggest question facing physics in your
opinion well it partly depends on what
kind of physics you're talking about I
of course come from the arena of
fundamental physics gravity quantum
mechanics things of that sort and in
that domain I would say the fundamental
question facing us is what is face and
what is time that may sound silly right
we've been formulating our theories
within an ocean of space and time for
centuries Isaac Newton puts forward
space is the arena time is that which
allows us to measure the change has
occurred and the events of the universe
take place within that rubric Einstein
comes along and realizes well it's more
complex more subtle space and time can
warp and curve and in that way there are
participants in the cosmological
unfolding space expands time elapses at
different rates if you're near the edge
of a black hole if you're back here on
earth but all of that however insightful
it is doesn't tell us what space is
doesn't tell us what time is we can
measure these things with great
precision but we kind of don't know what
they are and progress has been made
there's work and string theory that
suggests that space and time may
themselves be made up of more
fundamental constituents and they may be
constituents that are some in some sense
threaded together held together by the
threads of quantum entanglement these
are very exciting ideas but they're
tentative so an answer to your question
I think the next big revolution will
come when these ideas are not so
tentative when we have consensus on what
space is and what
is with the hope that once we understand
things well I mean the pattern has
always been you don't understand
something you work hard at it
you research it you experiment you bang
on it with mathematical equations you do
understand it huh
fantastic next step you manipulate it
right quantum mechanics was just a
collection of ideas that allowed us to
better understand the hydrogen atom the
motion of electrons back in the 1920s
but now we regularly use quantum
mechanics to build things the devices of
everyday life rely upon quantum
mechanics so the pattern is you don't
understand something you work hard you
do understand it you work hard again and
now you can manipulate the thing that
you began with so if that pattern were
to hold true with space and time you
don't really understand it you work hard
you understand it better
Einstein relativity and so forth but if
we can go that next step and really
fully understand it and by that means be
able to manipulate space and time the
way we manipulate electrons with quantum
mechanics Wow what could that portend
what could that mean what could that
yield the ability to willfully
manipulate space and time that's that's
that's exciting that's what the next
generation of you young physics
enthusiasts you may enter that domain of
being able to manipulate space and time
and we'll I hope I'm around when when
that development takes place na'vi ball
asks hi professor
how does general relativity help in the
formation of the GPS Global Positioning
System yeah that takes us another
example right I mean I just mentioned
how quantum mechanics allows you to
manipulate electrons and that allows for
the whole modern electronics industry
relying upon quantum mechanics the GPS
is an example where Einstein's general
relativity
has concrete applications why
well how does the GPS system work right
so the GPS system you have these
satellites orbiting the Earth and we
have these devices that can communicate
with the satellites they can receive
signals from the satellites and if your
device receives a signal say from three
of those satellites and those signals
are time-stamped so you know when those
signals left the satellite by virtue of
the time difference of the arrival of
those signals you can calculate where
you must be on planet earth because you
can calculate your distance from each of
the satellites and that can uniquely
delineate which point you are occupying
on planet earth but critical to that is
that the satellites are all completely
synced up in terms of time that they are
registering twelve moon at the same 12
moon and it must also be the case that
your phone is ticking off time at a rate
that allows it to stay in sync with the
clocks on the satellite but bear in mind
the satellites are farther away from
planet Earth
experiencing less of a gravitational
field according to Einstein's general
relativity
their clocks intrinsically are ticking
off time at a faster rate if you didn't
take that general relativistic effect
into account then all the calculations
that I just spoke about check the time
differences in triangulating your
location would be completely off they'd
be wrong the clocks on the satellite and
the clocks on your iPhone would be so
out of whack relative to one another
that the GPS system would fail so you
have to include the general relativistic
corrections in order that the GPS system
works and indeed that's what is done so
it's a beautiful example where the
general theory of relativity comes right
into our pockets when we're carrying
around a phone that has GPS sensitivity
embedded in its technology so yeah quite
wonderful to see general relativity as
an applied science in that particular
way okay let's see what we got going on
here
Wow 34:20 usually it's around four
o'clock that I say I'm about to stop and
then I keep on going for another hour
but so we were doubt 2.71828 one eight
hello professor what do you think oh no
where did it go wow you know I touched
this thing and it Scrolls by so fast
sorry II which I guess was the number
that you had there I've lost you and I'm
scrolling back to try to find your
question I can't find it oh no no there
is way up there a weirdo asks hello
professor what do you think about pure
mathematics I'm in favor of pure
mathematics I support pure mathematics I
would vote for pure mathematics I agree
with the platform of pure mathematics
and what I mean by that is you know
people are motivated to do work by
different considerations when I was in
college I was thinking about doing pure
math and the reason I wound up not doing
it is it sort of felt to me like the
problems in pure math are the problems
that we make up we envision interesting
questions like how many spheres can you
pack in a particular shape or what is
the density of prime numbers if you look
at the number line or things of that
sort right and they're interesting
questions but they are ultimately
questions that we come up with what I
found more appealing about physics is
that the mathematics that you do is
trying to solve problems that you don't
come up with but rather that the
universe comes up with the universe
presents us with gravity we want to
understand it the universe presents us
with electrons we want to understand
them so somehow it felt to me that the
math is being used to answer questions
that are less arbitrary
that are part of how reality is
constructed so that motivates me more
than the questions of pure mathematics
but oftentimes the questions of pure
mathematics in time have proven to be
relevant to physics Einstein borrowed
the pure mathematical insights of Gauss
and Riemann and others in order to
understand curved surfaces but the
surface that Einstein had in mind was
face time the manifold called space time
so it's really exciting when the pure
mathematics unexpectedly has an impact
on physics but you have to do whatever
fires you up and pure mathematicians are
fired up more by questions of their own
making within their the universe if you
will of math as opposed the universe of
space-time and stuff okay Seth Catalano
asked what is a good geometric intuition
for what the Einstein tensor measures as
the Riemann tensor measures the
acceleration of the separation of two
paths and the Rema and the Ricci tensor
measures the change in in volume so so
here's here's how I think a good way of
measuring of thinking about the Riemann
tensor maybe I'm gonna go back over here
so starting a broadcast let me go to my
iPad can it work yes it does okay so
when you think about the the Riemann
tensor so if you have our Alpha Beta
Gamma Delta the question is what is this
thing
measuring and what I like to think about
this measuring is it's a measure of what
I have over here it's a measure of the
degree of variation so let me choose a
different color here so imagine you've
got a shape like this and you take some
tangent
over here give it a different color come
on hot pink is a nice one let's say you
have a tangent vector over here and you
slide it around to let's say you slide
it around over to this location boy have
a little bit of trouble here
little bit of lag there we go and that's
sort of path 1 motion but let's say you
take that same vector and you parallel
transport it around the loop in the
other direction and let's say it takes
you over here and in general as I was
saying before on a curved surface the
vectors that you get by that parallel
motion will not agree what does the
Riemann tensor do the Riemann tensor
measures the difference in the direction
that those two vectors point and that's
really what it does and as we'll see
when we come back to your daily equation
next week I may derive it in some detail
but you'll see quite directly that the
Riemann tensor is nothing but the gadget
that captures the difference between two
vectors parallel transported opposite
directions around a loop and that is the
diagnostic for the surface being curved
and that is indeed with Riemann tensor
measures ok so what do we got do I have
my iPad down I think I do tell me if I
don't Agee writes AG until the end of
time oh nice so you have the title of my
book you wrote about the infinitesimal
odds of park was arranging into orderly
low and tropic States billions of people
interact with reality daily so why
haven't we heard or seen said phenomenon
and and yeah you're right you know I I'm
fond of emphasizing that the second law
of thermodynamics talks about the
increase of entropy but it's not a law
really listen to me
the second law of thermodynamics is not
a law in the usual way that
Newton's law is a law or Einstein's
equations are a lawful description of
how a physical system evolves the second
law of thermodynamics speaks to an
overwhelming likelihood of what will
happen and the overwhelming likelihood
is that entropy will increase common
examples if I were to drop my iphone a
knock Oh Apple product again you're
going to accuse me a pot product
placement so let me take something else
so if I were to take this candle alright
it's a glass jar if I was to drop this
we know it will smash on the floor
that's going from order to disorder the
reverse process is possible where as the
questioner asks the shards of glass on
the floor in principle they can jump off
the floor reassemble into this pristine
glass candle the question is why haven't
you ever seen that it's a very
straightforward answer if you look at
the number of events that all the people
on planet earth right so I don't know
how many people have lived since the
beginning of our species I'm gonna make
a wild guess let's call it I don't know
50 billion people 100 billion I don't
know so there's some number you can look
it up you tell me think about the number
of seconds call an event sort of an a it
takes one second to see an event think
about the number of seconds that have
elapsed since the beginning of our
species that is the number of seconds
that people have lived that's a number I
don't know what that numbers gonna be I
don't know let me call it I don't know
it's called ten to the twenty you know I
don't care something like that if you
compare that number to the odds of the
glass shards jumping off the floor
because the floor boards and the
molecules of air in the room all reverse
their motion and reverse their members
in such a way that they hit the floor
boards and the floor birds jiggle in
such a right way that they kicked the
glass shards off my floor to reassemble
into this glass the odds of that is
spectacular less than ten to the minus
twenty it
tend to a huge number and therefore it
is completely unsurprising that no one
has ever seen that process happen and no
one has ever seen an egg on smash no one
has ever seen a candle unburned no one
has ever seen a person resurrect or say
evolved from an elderly physical form to
a young physical form it's not that
these processes can't happen they are
allowed by the laws of physics it's just
that the odds of them happening is not
just small it's spectacularly smaller
than the number of events that every
human being who's ever lived has ever
encountered and that's why it makes
perfect sense that no one has ever known
in a replicable manner has ever claimed
that they have seen an entropic li
decreasing process to happen
that doesn't satisfy you feel free to
ask again but that is what it is let's
say we got mr. castle asks going to
black holes can photons be trapped in in
stable orbits outside of a black hole
photons can be trapped in orbits around
a black hole so maybe we'll do this if
you want I'm going to talk about the
black hole solution to Einstein's field
equations of general relativity and once
you have the solution you understand the
geometry outside of the black hole once
you understand the geometry the warps
and curves in the vicinity of a black
hole you can calculate how things will
move how do you calculate that objects
want to move along the shortest possible
trajectory they're called geodesics in
order to figure out the shortest
possible trajectory you need to know the
geometry once you know the geometry
you've got everything that you need in
order to figure out trajectories and
indeed you can find trajectories that
light will travel light itself will go
into orbit around a black hole but it's
not a stable orbit if you were to
perturb that orbit a little bit photon
goes one way or the other away from the
black hole or toward the black hole so
you can have photon orbits absolutely
that's that's pretty cool that's pretty
surprising in its own right
Brad Dibble asks dr. Greene I love
baseball and and physics great does the
Louisville Slugger in your room any
significance do I have that Slugger in
here maybe it maybe it's yeah actually
it is I see it in the back corner over
there does it have any significance well
I actually once did a physics video with
the New York Mets
you know baseball team New York Mets I
went to them and I described how the
various things like the Magnus force are
responsible for why a baseball curves
when a pitcher throws it appropriately I
described how
a baseball bat has a frequency response
function that determines where the sweet
spot on the bat will be when a batter is
swinging that bad
so I too love baseball mostly because my
son loves it and he sort of wrote me
back into the sport after I hadn't
really thought about it for for many
decades but the reason why I have the
Louisville Slugger in my room here is a
little less erudite than any of those
descriptions might suggest and by the
way you can find those mets videos those
baseball mitts videos online maybe it's
even on the World Science Vessel website
I don't know but the reason I have the
Louisville Slugger here is that I am in
a little writers cabin you can sort of
see I'm you know by a barn somewhat in
the woods I'm I don't know about 300
feet from the main house where my family
is and where I sleep I sometimes come
out here at night it's kind of dark
pitch dark and I'm always somewhat
concerned that a coyote
or a bear might want to have a
conversation and route from my house to
this cabin and so to dissuade certain
kinds of conversations with those wild
animals that I would prefer not to have
I bring the back with me no doubt in a
wrestling match with a coyote or a bear
I think I'd lose even with the baseball
bat but psychologically it makes me feel
a little more confident as I cross in
the darkness that is the only reason the
baseball bat is here let's see Robert
Taylor asks do we humans give meaning to
the universe and if not what is the
meaning of it all what is the meaning of
it all Robert Taylor asks and yeah you
know as you know you know the book I
wrote recently until the end of time a
little bit different from my previous
books and that it takes up questions
like that what is the meaning
of it all and and look my view on this
is is the following fundamentally there
is no meaning built into the
architecture of the world there is no
fundamental notion of meaning to use
another metaphor that's stitched into
the fabric of reality at rock-bottom as
I said before I believe and I think the
evidence strongly supports the
perspective but it doesn't prove it that
reality is nothing but stuff fundamental
ingredients governed by fundamental laws
that we may or may not currently have at
our disposal and that's it
so from that perspective you can't look
to physics to provide any notion of
meaning or purpose meaning or purpose
are concepts that really only come into
existence when certain sophisticated
refined collections of particles are
able to form and they form by the
process of natural selection that's why
we are here the fundamental laws are
supporting a process that Darwin was
able to identify in which molecules can
become ever better adapted to their
environment ultimately allowing complex
structures like life and like conscious
beings to exist and therefore when we
ask ourselves about meaning and purpose
of it all we are asking a question that
couldn't even be asked until
self-reflective conscious beings emerged
and therefore what kind of answer should
we search for so we search for an answer
in the fundamental equations no
fundamental equations don't know about
this notion of meaning and purpose where
should we search for the answer we have
to search within ourselves because we
are the conduit by which this question
is able to be asked and so ultimately
it's a very personal question this way
of thinking about things
frees us up at least from my perspective
to stop looking for some meaning out
there in the world and each of us is
charged with a task of manufacturing our
own meaning and by the word manufacturer
I don't mean to denigrate in any way
shape or form the concept of
or purpose or meaning not at all I think
that the fact that we manufacture it
makes it exquisite it grand eise's it
because unlike other approaches that may
look out to some being or look out to
something in the world to bestow meaning
upon us that version we're just wearing
someone else's notion of value in person
some external forces conception of value
and purpose it is so much more noble to
come up with our own value our own
purpose and that's something that Robert
Taylor you need to I knew I everyone
needs to do it on their own they look
for mine my perspective understanding
physics understanding the universe
that's part of where my value and
purpose comes into the story having
these conversations spreading insight
that physics has revealed that gives me
a sense of a value and purpose as well
revealing some fundamental quality of
reality however minor it might be on
those occasions I have felt enhanced
value and purpose through that
achievement these are the things that we
use and of course my family right my
wife my kids that is a source of great
value and purpose as well so you won't
find it written into the Stars you won't
find it written into the molecules
you'll find it if you allow yourself the
freedom to make it up find what gives
you that sense of purpose and value and
that is a highly personal highly
subjective but deeply exquisite way of
addressing the question of meaning I
mean
if you guys feel differently than that
no doubt some of you have a radically
different perspective put it in the
comments I'd be more than happy to hear
different views all right carry on with
the more physics oriented questions that
I see coming first SCI asks psi I guess
our side the Greek letter SCI my
question is to dr. green yes they're all
coming to me unfiltered will matter
decay in the future will protons decay
and if they will does that mean the time
stops will time come to an end so we we
do not know if protons will decay we
believe that every other particle except
the lightest ones like electrons
neutrinos and photons the belief is that
they are likely stable but conglomerates
right now a proton is three quarks the
conglomerates we believe will all fall
apart but we don't know that for sure
neutrons certainly fall apart short
period of time
hold the neutron in your hand you know a
bunch of them in your hand after you
know a short period of time ten minutes
you know half of them will have
disintegrated protons we have tested
we've looked at large huge tanks of
water and other fluids looking for one
measly proton to fall apart
we've never measured it our mathematics
suggests that protons will fall apart
different theories give different
timescales ten to the 35 ten to the
thirty eight years is the half-life for
a proton but as yet we don't know but I
would say that most physicists
anticipate that protons are not forever
that they will also fall apart now the
question is when they all do fall apart
does that mean time stopped since people
use that language when all complex
matter has disintegrated all stars have
disintegrated into a spray of particles
is it all gone in the sense that time
doesn't take forward well time may end
in the sense that there won't be any
meaningful notion of change
if all you've got it particles floating
through the void then it kind of doesn't
matter whether one particles here and
one particles there or one particles
move so in that sense there won't be
anything happening and if time is a
measure of change and change has to rely
on things happening then yeah in a sense
and a poetic sense timeless stopped but
particles will still be moving and
they're moving through time and so in
that sense time may go on forever even
though there won't be anything
interesting happening now again if
you're interested in this in more detail
chapter 10 of my book until the end of
time takes this on and notes that in the
very far future if you wait like 10 to
the 10 to the sixty-eight years then
even these particles floating through
the void can on occasion randomly
coalesce into interesting structures
structures that in fact may be able to
think - Kaja Tate that's weird that's
curious
wait ten to the ten to the sixty eight
years and a brain a human brain may
spontaneously form out there in the boy
towns nutty maybe nutty we generally use
this as a diagnostic tool to try to
modify our theories to not allow this
process to happen these are called
Boltzmann brains after Ludwig Boltzmann
so if you're interested in the idea of
both membranes again you can reach after
10 up until the end of time but barring
those kind of rare occurrences that may
happen in the far future the absence of
change in some poetic sense can be
interpreted as the absence of time so
yes in short to that question a campus
crypt I'd I'm reading until the end of
time and almost every footnote redirects
to chapter 10 that's not quite you it's
not that every footnote redirects to
chapter 10 but chapter 10 is where it
kind of all comes together where I lay
out the very very far future and in a
book that's called until the end of time
the chapter that takes you toward the
end
chime is end of time is going to be a
pretty pretty vital one and that's why
chapter 10 has the prominence that it
does Demond Keter Paul asked as a spring
gain mass when it's compressed does
potential energy convert to mass and the
answer is heck yeah so if you have a
spring and you compress it right and you
were to weigh that spring on an
incredibly precise scale and compare the
reading when the spring is in its
relaxed ordinary state the reading on
the scale will be bigger when the spring
is compressed the energy that you push
into it as you say it's this potential
energy but Einsteins e equals mc-squared
takes into account all energy it's
really saying that energy and mass are
different labels for the same kind of
thing and so by putting more energy in
you've put more mass in and that mass
would be reflected on the reading of a
scale similarly as I'm fond of using as
an example if I have a flashlight and I
put the flashlight on a spectacular
sensitive scale and I turn the
flashlight on or the torch as some of
you like to use the language as the
light races away from the flashlight it
takes away energy right light has energy
it's taking away energy from the
flashlight taking away energy means
you're taking away mass which means the
reading on this fantastically sensitive
scale will go down if you keep the
button in the on position for the
flashlight tee-ball ask dear professor
green greetings from god ran away don't
do that I'm gonna try to find that
question I should never touch the the
pad here when I'm in the middle of
asking a question that's why this
happens to me I'm trying to find your
question I'm scroll
up maybe ask it again I can't see it
unfortunately so I'm going to move on to
another question
sorry about that Tybalt mr. castle asks
dear sir other equations that you don't
understand it depends what you mean by
understand you know I feel like I
understand the the key equations of
modern physics in the sense that I know
where they came from I know what they're
trying to tell us but do I understand
them deeply intuitively in my bones some
of them yes some of them no I often find
that I have to go back and rethink
things especially when I'm teaching a
subject even if I think and I understand
the subject inside out I'll come upon
some equations say wait a second
wait what is that really telling me and
where does that really come from and
what's the chain of reasoning that gets
me to that equation I find that I have
to go back and refresh myself in order
to keep the chain of reasoning really
sharp inside my brain so you should
never be what's the word you should
never be what's the words not
disgruntled distressed it's a very basic
word and you should never feel bad you
know tell me what word I'm looking for
if you if you sort of find that you have
to go back and relearn something from
the past I've got to do it all the time
so in that sense I have to refresh my
understanding but there certainly are
fields of mathematics that I've given up
on somebody asked earlier about math
that I was surprised I had a role in
physics and I described algebraic
geometry as an example of a field that
unexpectedly I had to learn parts of it
to do certain research in string theory
but there are other parts of algebraic
geometry you know in the book of joel
harris has a beautiful book on algebraic
geometry and there are chapters in that
book that
defeated me I wanted to understand those
chapters and I never felt like I really
did and their other chapters that I
didn't even bother to try to read so in
that sense there are equations in pure
mathematics that I feel stretched my
brain to the limit and could I have
learned them if I if I really really
really tried maybe but it was the
getting to a point in certain of those
undertakings that I felt like every time
I went further in understanding part of
the subject another part of it would
sort of disappear as I was like a
conservation of the amount of brain
space that my brain was willing to allow
the equations of algebraic geometry to
fully inhabit so yes they're definitely
things that I've tried to understand and
felt like I didn't fully master or felt
like I had reached my my limit okay
Ludwig von Beethoven asked will you
write not a biography someday in the
distant future great source of
inspiration to me and many others who
I'll be honored to be enriched by your
life experience von Beethoven um I don't
know um I'm not sure it's never really
occurred to me but you know in in my
latest book there is much more personal
reflection than I've had in any previous
book and and some people have asked me
why not in a in a accusatory way but
they were just curious about my own
thought process that led me to include
more personal reflections in until the
end of time let me tell you why the
point of the book until the end of time
is that there's not one way of
understanding reality we physicists
focus on the fundamental particles and
the fundamental laws and that's what
we're really talking about here today
but to have a full account of the world
as experienced by a human being you need
to layer various other accounts into
that story you need to layer the account
that the chemist gives at the biologist
gives but you can't stop there you need
to give the account that the philosopher
gives or the neuroscientist gives or the
artist gives
or the theologian gives and all of these
accounts serve to enrich your
understanding of what life and what
reality what the world is all about and
so it felt to me that it would really be
unfortunate in a book that's talking
about these layered account these
layered stories to not include the only
human story that I have direct access to
which is my own so at various moments
you will see that I do layer in personal
experience and personal reflection as
part of that nested account so that the
narrative can be as rich as possible but
rather I'll go further one day and and
actually write an autobiography I I
don't know I don't know we'll see we'll
see how things progress okay
megha asks if all information is stored
in quantum entanglement doesn't that
mean eternal life actually happens and I
would say no not at all
so you can have a system whose
information content is fully stored in
the quantum state of that system and if
you then conclude or at least
hypothesize and it seems to be well
bolstered by our understanding of
physics that information is is not
destroyed that the information is always
there at best what I'd be willing to say
is that in principle all the information
contained in a given human brain that
information can in principle be
recreated by infinitely precise
measurements that take place after that
being may have expired but at best you
can imagine using that information to
recreate the original living system it's
not the developing system itself is
eternal you know it's hard to define
what you actually mean by death that's
actually reading a book reasoning by a
philosopher who is you know struggling
to give a precise definition of what it
means when we're when we die but I'm I'm
pretty satisfied with the
straightforward definition you know when
this physical structure called Brian
green and when it no longer functions
when it no longer carries out the basic
processes that we define as living when
no longer breeze or eats or thinks
that's to me when it has died and when
it dies sure in principle the
information content and all the
constituents and their various
interrelationships could in principle be
recorded and could in principle be
recreated but still I'd be dead there
could be a recreation of me perhaps
maybe we'll get to that point maybe you
know in the sci-fi books we imagine
uploading ourselves into a different
physical structure will will that ever
happen I have no idea but even if it
does happen it's not to say that this
living system that originated the
thoughts and feelings and emotions and
memories
one have died it will have died will
simply have found a way of capturing its
patterns and allowing this patterns
either to be recreated or to persist
that's that's different from saying that
the living system itself is eternal
oh yes Joe Harris is the other author as
Evy notes to me on on on that book so
Griffiths and Harris yes its Griffiths
and Harris that's what it is exactly
right thank you let's see what else we
have somebody is directing me to a
question on Twitter but I don't know
what question that is sorry let's see so
I am I like that I am asked what is the
difference between gravity and quantum
gravity and why are we after the latter
why are we after quantum gravity so so
it's it's quite straightforward I am and
and the answer simply this so in the
early days of trying to understand
reality Isaac Newton gave us the
universal law of gravity that perhaps
you know about F equals G m1 m2 over R
squared we call that a classical formula
because it does not take into account
the realizations that we acquired in the
1920s and 1930s that the world's not
actually governed by the classical laws
of Newton there's another class of laws
the quantum laws and we've been very
good at applying those quantum laws and
situations of individual particles
collections of particles molecules and
atoms and so forth the equation that we
make use of is called Schrodinger's
equation now although we understand
gravity in the macroscopic way that it
manifests itself a la Newton in F equals
G m1 m2 over R squared there are
situations in which Newton gravity and
quantum small things need to be blended
together so a quantum theory of gravity
is a theory of gravity that will work
not just for stars and planets but will
work for individual particles like
electrons and quarks and protons and
moreover it will work in any situation
where a quantum description of the
ingredients is necessary so a quantum
theory of gravity blends the rules of
quantum mechanics
with the rules of gravity in a manner
that allows us to apply the
gravitational force in any circumstance
not just planets and galaxies when
things are big but also to the realm of
small so being even more precise
Einstein gave us a more more refined
classical theory of gravity the general
theory of relativity is a classical
theory it doesn't speak to quantum
physics so our goal has been to blend in
Stein's theory of gravity the theory if
you will of big things with quantum
mechanics our theory of small things so
that we have one unified description
that works for the small works for the
big works for everything in between
right now we have a fractured
description we use quantum mechanics for
the small Newton or general relativity
for the big depending on the
circumstance we don't want two theories
there's one universe
there should be one theory that puts it
all together that's the goal of a
quantum theory of gravity all right so
let's see what we have you sir on your
book fabric of the cosmos you have
mentioned that space and time are moving
equal to the speed of light please
explain to me as one of your readers so
I think what Safi cate rasa is referring
to suffocate suffocate rozzers referring
to is that any individual can be thought
of as though they are moving through
space-time at the speed of light what do
I mean by that well for light it's
obvious light just moves at the speed of
light but what about me
right here imagine that from my frame of
reference I'm not moving through space
at all
am i executing some motion and the
answer is I am I'm moving through time
right my clock is ticking off second
after second after second so if we don't
just think about motion through space
but also think about
through time that I'm moving right now
I'm moving through time at what speed am
i moving through time and it turns out
that one way of interpreting on some
special relativity is that I'm moving
through time at the speed of light and
in fact any motion at all when thought
about not just as motion through space
but as motion through space-time has a
speed equal to the speed of light why is
that useful that's useful for the
following reason if I now get up and
start to move through space according to
Einstein Einstein doesn't say it this
way this is sort of my interpretation
and there are others who say this too
but but I kind of saw myself writing
this interpretation down the first time
in the elegant universe it was but
whatever who cares about credit or
anything like that but when I get up and
start to move through space I divert
some of my previous motion through time
into that motion through space and
therefore my passage through time and
motion through time slows down when I
get up to move through space it affects
my passage through time that's why if I
look at you getting up and walking and I
look at your wristwatch I will see your
wants ticking off time slowly why the
previous motion that you had was all
through time you got up and you have a
fixed amount of it you're moving through
at a fixed speed and therefore if you
get up you divert some of that fixed
speed from the previous motion through
time into your motion through space and
therefore your motion through time slows
therefore your clock ticks off time more
slowly that's one way of thinking about
why it is that time slows down for an
object that you are looking at in motion
why does it slow down because as a fixed
amount of motion through space-time and
it is diverting some of that motion into
motion through space therefore the
previous motion through time must give
up some of its speed it must slow down
clocks must tick at a slower rate that
to me is the most beautiful most
intuitive understanding of why it is
that when an object moves time slows
down Pericles Mello asks do you have a
video on the double slit experiment that
shows that and observe it behind this
that collapses the wavefunction and the
pattern of superposition on the screen I
don't have a video of it but I'm
wondering Pericles Melo why you're
asking for one because your description
is pretty darn good right in your mind's
eye you can picture no observer you got
the particles going through the two
slits you get the interference pattern
light dark light dark light dark on the
screen if you then modify the experiment
by putting an observer on the other side
of the barrier who measures the slit
through which a particle goes that
interaction changes the experiment has
it changed it the particles will no
longer land in this nice light dark
light dark spread instead they will fan
out and just give us an overall smear on
that back screen no interference pattern
at all so your description captures it
right so I think your mental image is
just as good as any video image that I
could give you amanda says time has to
compromise for space yeah that's right
Here I am my watch is ticking off time
all right I get up and I start to walk
and you will see time compromising for
space-time is giving up some of its
fixed light speed motion so that some of
that motion can be diverted into my
motion through space that's it that's
really what Einstein found in the
special theory
of relativity totally intuitive when you
think about it that way however strange
the implication may be okay
oh okay t-bolt has reacted question
thank you and I'm not going to touch so
I'll read a dear professor Greene a
recent became a big fan of yours
exclamation point thank you my question
is or was why our past present and
future and illusion thank you very much
so
so teapot you're referring to a quote of
Einstein's a famous quote it was a quote
that Einstein wrote to the widow of his
friend
the Bissell and what Einstein said to be
Tso's Widow was the fact that he has
departed the world a little before me
has no meaning because the distinction
between past present and future is only
an illusion however persistent that's
the translation that I prefer of that
quote I think it's a quite beautiful
quite poetic quote how do you interpret
that physically what was Einstein
thinking well look you know he was
writing to the widow of a friend so
trying to overlay a precise
interpretation might seem a little crass
but let me give you the interpretation
that I think works best so in the
special theory of relativity we learned
that our clocks tick off time at
different rates if we are moving
relative to each other what does that
mean that means that what you consider
to be right now may not be what I
consider to be right now
you're now maybe what I consider past
you're now maybe what i consider future
and similarly for your consideration of
my notion of now which means if you
consider everybody's perspective imagine
that they're our perspective all
throughout the cosmos even hypothetical
perspectives all moving relative to one
another and so forth and if you take
into account every individual's notion
of now then you basically will span all
moments of time moments that I consider
to be way in the past someone way out
there will say no no that happened just
now notions that I say haven't yet
occurred are in my future someone way
out there say no no that occurred just
now and therefore the distinction that I
make between past present and future is
not a distinction that holds for all the
individuals out there so at the level of
the individual there is past present and
future for sure
if you lift yourself out of the
perspective of the individual and
consider a more global perspective there
is no organization to past present and
future that works globally
it's all individualistic it's all
subjective and therefore since it's
subjective Einstein is saying in that
sense it's an illusion it is not woven
into the fundamental fabric of the world
this distinction meaning past present
and future in that sense it is an
illusion ok what else do we have here
what time is it oh it's it's 5 o'clock
but if you still want to chat a little
bit further I'm I'm happy to do that
it's uh it's 236 in India you all should
sleep now one of the viewer says some
viewer who's called viewer of all things
could a new universe spontaneously come
into existence when another universe has
expanded to emptiness and and and yes I
mean it's conceivable that the Big Bang
is an event that can happen arbitrarily
many times the required conditions for a
Big Bang is to have enough uniform
energy in a small enough region of space
it's usually carried by what's called
the Implanon field in the conventional
mathematical description and that then
yields this repulsive force that blows
space to swell enormous Li and in
principle quantum mechanics allows you
to calculate the likelihood that such a
uniform sufficiently dense region of
inflict on energy could form at any
given moment and the answer for that is
a small but nonzero number so if you
wait sufficiently long yes you can
imagine whole big bangs happening long
after our universe has expanded in the
language of the questioner expanded into
what is as close to nothing as you could
imagine ok what else do we have
unorthodox what do you think of flat
earthers well you know there are truths
about the world that are objective there
are truths about the world that are
subjective that speak more to our place
in the world as opposed to qualities of
the world that are accessible to anybody
the earth in the objective sense is not
flat the earth in any objective notion
of truth is not flat but if someone uses
the notion that earth is flat as a
metaphor that helps them to better
appreciate where they fit in to the
reality that they inhabit and so bit but
goodness gracious keep straight your
metaphors and your reality there's
poetry and there are facts and the fact
of the matter is that the world has a
particular objective shape it is a
sphere as close to a sphere
it is not flat but I'm all too happy in
poetry to hear about Flat Earth in
economics to hear about flattening the
disparities among different places on
earth but that's metaphor keep your
metaphors straight keep your poetry stay
keep it all beautiful and wonderful and
insightful and subjective just don't
mistake it for objective truth okay what
do we have here Oh t-bone
thank you very much thank you I
appreciate your response to my answer
what else do we have here
why does hackers lab asks why does
string theory require 11 dimensions of
space and the extra dimensions of
strength their particular number is one
that I have tried ever since writing the
elegant universe to find some
non-technical way of explaining that and
I really failed on that I don't I've
never seen a non-technical explanation
for why string theory requires extra
dimension so let me give you the semi
technical explanation which is the best
that I can do there is an equation
within string theory which must vanish
for the theory to be consistent all
right meant that already is technical
from the get-go so I apologize for that
that equation takes the form it turns
out a complicated expression times
something really simple so in the
simplest case it's just d minus 10 where
D is the number of space-time dimensions
in string theory and so for this to
vanish the complicated thing all it
doesn't vanish the simple thing must so
that you have something times zero
how does D minus ten equals zero D
equals ten I swear to you that's really
what happens it's a calculation in
perturbative string theory they get two
to ten as a number of space-time
dimensions to get to 11 you then realize
that that perturbative calculation
leaves out one dimension this is what
Edie Witten alerted us to in a beautiful
lecture at University of Southern
California in 1995 and and so we've
pieced together our understanding of
eleven space-time dimensions but I wish
I could just say to you hey you know
just think of a marble on a trampoline
and then give you a few more words and
we get to the extra dimensions
I've never succeeded in doing that I've
never seen anyone who has so
unfortunately I can't give you a nice
non-technical explanation for the extra
de Levin extra dimensions now Joelle
jarvan then
is making good reference that it goes to
11 no doubt that is a spinal tap
reference if I understand Joel correctly
where one of the musicians is so proud
of his new amplifier because whereas
most amplifiers have a top level of 10
his amplifier has a top level of 11 so
so if that if that explanation gives you
any insight fantastic for me it doesn't
do much beyond make me smile but that
there's nothing wrong with smiling aya
Hasson asked what is the use of string
theory what is the use of string theory
well the use of string theory is number
one it is our most promising theoretical
approach for lending quantum mechanics
in the general theory of relativity so
there it is right within string theory
the mathematics makes clear that quantum
mechanics and gravity can harmoniously
co-exist this is a big problem a big
challenge
what else does string theory do well it
shows us at least in principle how
basically every discovery from the past
50 years in physics finds a natural home
within the mathematical structure of
string theory the Higgs particle it can
fit engaged symmetries that we use to
describe the electromagnetic and the
nuclear forces they have a natural home
the discrete symmetries that protect
certain properties of particles like
stability of the proton base of a
natural home within strengths eon and on
string theory not only puts gravity and
quantum mechanics together but it allows
all of the major discoveries of the past
to also be brought within the fold
string theory is also valuable as a tool
other subjects have found that string
theory allows you to make calculations
that would be horrific without the
mathematical tool of string theory so
there's a great deal of use of string
theory in the physical sciences but the
real question is
is string theory the right way to go if
you want to find the deepest laws of the
particles and the deepest laws that
govern them and on that we don't know we
are still struggling to connect string
theory with observations in a manner
that would address that question so
there's a lot of use of string theory a
lot a mathematical user strengths here I
should have mentioned that some of my
own work open the door for string theory
solving certain math problems that
mathematicians were stumped by and
string theory can answer those questions
so on the math front on it's
applications and other fields and
potentially as a unified theory of all
forces and all matter so why do we work
on it we work on it for that reason the
potential is enormous when will we know
if string theory is Right theory through
observation and experiment I don't have
a crystal ball
I don't know it'd be great if it was
soon but the world universe doesn't look
to satisfy our timetable the universe
will reveal its secrets when we have the
capacity to interrogate it in the right
way with the right equipment so Damon
Keter Paul asks is it resolved that free
will does not exist any logic in favor
of free will any any good reads on the
subject well Damon I'll refer you to my
own thinking on this I'll briefly
describe it but Chapter five of my new
book until the end of time it's called
something like particles and
consciousness and it comes to the
conclusion that there is no free will at
least in the traditional sense of the
term the sense that we all have that we
are the ultimate originators of our
actions we are the full author of the
things that we do that's sensation that
intuition runs into problems it runs
into serious problems because when you
recognize and not everybody agrees with
this I mean there is a review of my book
that came out just the other
where the reviewer clearly does not buy
into one of the key assumptions that I
make which is fundamentally the world
physically is made of particles governed
by laws you don't need anything else
beyond that to explain the phenomenon of
existence now is that absolutely true I
think it is many others I'm not alone
I'm not trying to say this is an
original idea nor am i trying to point
to others to bolster my position but the
fact of the matter is that many people
who have thought hard about this have
come to the same conclusion there is no
life force out there there is no
consciousness field that we somehow tap
into the world is made of ingredients
governed by laws and once you accept
that and you don't have to I don't need
you to accept that I'm simply giving you
a conclusion based on that way of
looking at the world once you accept
that then free will goes out the window
because we as collections of particles
are governed by mathematical law and the
motion of our particles therefore is not
under our control and my dog Luna is
clearly agreeing with me one more time
Luna let's hear you do you agree the dog
community agrees with no free will and
that's just being silent but once you
recognize that your particles are under
marching orders dictated by mathematical
decree and once you recognize that every
choice you make every decision you make
is nothing but your particle is moving
one way or another inside your brain or
your body's particles moving one way or
another you don't have any choice in how
those particles move those particles are
fully governed by quantum mechanical
marching orders and in that sense the
traditional notion that you can
intercede makes no sense it's not as
I've said before as if the laws of
physics are constructed in a way say for
me that they say hey particle is making
a Brian green follow Schrodinger's
equation
until Bryan's about to make a decision
then hold wait for him to make a
decision and once he makes a decision
carry out the decision that he made no
there's no place in the fundamental laws
for me to have any role like that
whatsoever so in that sense the
intuitive notion that we are these
agents volitional agents that have
choices and decisions at our disposal in
that sense it's wrong the decisions
happen and we recognize when they happen
but we in some sense are pulled along by
the very same laws that pull along our
particles now again
are there other perspectives absolutely
and in my book I give some of the other
perspectives I don't think they're right
and yet there are many opinions and as
yet we don't have enough data to fully
articulate an unassailable argument that
would establish the position that I just
laid out to be true but I strongly
suspect that it is true okay what else
do we have here give one that has not
asked a question before Bob g'day asks
dr. green are quantum fields the basic
building blocks of the universe well our
most refined and tested description of
the world is in terms of quantum field
theory so it is fields that are governed
by the generalization of Schrodinger's
equation from particles to fields it's
the same equation just now apply to the
ingredient of fields and fields are able
to create particles so fields are able
to embrace both the more spread-out
quality of a field like you know an
electromagnetic field light as well
spread out but the mathematics is
simultaneously able to describe the more
particulate entities the small
excitations of a field so if you were to
ask me what is the fundamental
description of the world that has
achieved a level of consensus because of
observation experiment then I would
agree that it is quantum field theory
and it may be the quantum field theory
is the be-all and end-all in fact
there's evidence that string theory is
equivalent to quantum field theory just
sort of rearranges the calculations and
the ingredients in a different way so in
that sense even string theory may be
nothing more than quantum field theory
so the answer to your question is it
might be yes humility suggests strongly
that we should be tentative and say this
is our current level of understanding it
could change 5 10 100 years from now but
yes based on our current level of
understanding that's where we are all
right let's see let's see
I wonder if we should start to wrap this
up as I'm starting to lose my voice but
let's just see what else comes in and
keep forgetting to look at the Twitter
list but it doesn't seem to have been
updated or have a Facebook lift so Cova
smiley from Facebook asks if gravity can
bend light how can it not slow light
down and that is a very very good
question and here's the answer so when
light travels from our macroscopic
perspective we might see it traveling on
some curved trajectory and it's going by
the Sun we say the bund the Sun bends
the light bends the trajectory of the
light but if we now put ourselves
actually in the shoes of the photon
itself the light itself what it actually
is doing it's going on the straightest
trajectory available to us it goes along
a geodesic in the environment so the
macroscopic global view of this curved
trajectory is actually nothing but the
photon traveling along the straightest
path available to it the shortest
rejector you sort of familiar with this
you know on earth when you get on an
airplane and you go over a long distance
sometimes the trajectory takes you over
the North Pole or something you're like
what in the world why would we be
traveling along that trajectory you're
your brain and your image of a flat map
would suggest a different path but
actually the shortest path the
straightest possible path on a sphere is
a great circle an arc of a great circle
and sometimes those arcs pass over the
North Pole so the light itself is not
actually from its perspective going and
a bendy way at all locally it's going on
the straightest possible path so its
speed locally is always equal to the
speed
light is always going in a nice straight
trajectory it's just when you piece
together all those straight trajectories
from a global perspective it looks like
it went on a bent trajectory but
velocity is a local notion it's what is
its velocity at a given moment at a
given location it's always the speed of
light and it's always traveling in a
straight line okay what else I do it
that was a good question on Facebook
maybe another one on Facebook some there
there long to read so I'm going to go
back to the shorter one on on YouTube
reckless abandon asks about background
know maybe recklessly Ben is having a
side conversation with Konstantinos
panagiotis talking about background
independence the electrode by Smolin and
and rivaly so me let me talk about
background independence since you guys
are having out your passing notes to
each other behind my back so I'm gonna
jump into this background independence
conversation and this is a conversation
I've had with Lee Smolin many times and
I think we see eye to eye on it so loop
quantum gravity from the get-go has this
quality of background independence which
means that the the equations are not
tied to any given shape for space-time
they're agnostic with respect to the
shape of space-time and that's a good
thing because ideally you don't want to
put space-time into your theory you want
it to emerge from your theory and loop
quantum gravity promises that from the
get-go in string theory the way we have
developed the theory is in what's known
as perturbation theory and that's now
we've gone beyond that with certain
developments in the last decade or so
but let me just go back to the beginning
as it's easier to describe so we
initially described string theory in
terms of small fluctuations about a
given background
and therefore the claim was made that
string theory is not background
independence you sort of got to give the
shape of space-time and then gravity
amounts to little tiny ripples imposed
on that pre-existing shape for
space-time so there was a conversation
that was happening for a while that loop
quantum gravity is background
independent and string theory is not
background independent but the fact of
the matter is in our understanding of
string theory we can arbitrarily perturb
that background get to a different shape
and then talk about graviton zazz little
fluctuations about that new background
so what I like to say is string theory
in that formulation doesn't have
manifest background independence there
is a background in our description but
the equations are sufficiently general
that they are amenable to an arbitrary
change of that background so while they
don't have manifest background
independence they do have as much
background independence as they possibly
could given that that perturbation
theory needs you to specify a background
around which to perturb developments
more recently that have given us more
non perturbative formulations the ADF C
of T correspondence allows us to speak
in a manner that's more general than the
one that I just gave but the conclusion
is the same string theory is as
background independent as it possibly
could be expected to be okay hopefully
that helped in clarifying that side
conversation that you all were having
but through what we have here pure asks
your thoughts on the graviton you know
does it exist I think it probably does
exist I don't know if we're ever going
to detect an individual graviton again
gravity is an incredibly weak force it
is depending on you measure it something
like 40 orders of magnitude weaker than
the electromagnetic force if I had say
two electrons
repelling each other the strength of
that electromagnetic repulsion would be
40 orders of magnitude or sir larger
than their gravitational attraction
gravity is just really weak and a
graviton is the smallest packet the
smallest bundle of the spectacularly
weak force so to find the smallest part
of the weakest force is a huge
experimental challenge and not one that
I anticipate anytime soon that we will
overcome but do I think that the
graviton is real yeah I do okay what
else do we have here
um reckless abandon came back at me
that's what was fun but now that ran
away I think I know what it says I think
the question was doesn't the background
that you select around which you perturb
doesn't that define a vacuum stage yeah
it does so for any given geometrical
shape there is a vacuum state my point
is at string theory the equations are
not really tied in any fundamental way
to that shape because you are able to
perturb arbitrarily far away from that
shape you have the same darn equations
then you can consider small fluctuations
say to talk about a graviton about that
new vacuum state so the dependence on
the background is not a string theory
dependence per se it's a perturbation
theory dependence it's the way you're
analyzing the theory as opposed to an
intrinsic limitation of the theory
that's the point that I am making our
patek says can you finish the QA because
I need to go to sleep how about I will
tell you Arpit tech I give you
permission to go to sleep you're not
gonna miss anything well you may you may
MIT you know what on second thought are
putting up if you want to really hear
everything that's gonna happen here you
better stay awake for just another few
minutes I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap this up
pretty soon I always like to wrap it up
on up on a high note some question that
sort of blows me away and let's see what
we can do to get to that well here's a
here's a good one a frequent one but
Fatima Syed Hasan asks where does the
universe expand and I presume what that
means is sort of what does universe
expand into again it's a natural way of
thinking about things based upon
everyday experience man it's getting
pretty sunny in here boy and I don't
have any window shades but whatever so I
probably look like I'm in the witness
protection program probably half of my
face is bright and a half is dark but
the when you think about anything
expanding right when you think about a
balloon expanding when you think about
bread expanding it's always expanding
into a pre-existing space and therefore
you naturally imagine that when the
universe expands it too must expand into
a pre-existing space sort of some some
real estate that the universe has
somehow not yet occupied not yet claimed
hegemony over it must expand into that
and that may not be right in the
traditional way of thinking about the
expanding universe is not right we
imagine that as the universe expands it
creates the very space that it expands
into that space wasn't there before the
expansion the expansion is literally the
creation of new space new territory and
the universe inhabits it by virtue the
fact that that territory came into being
because the universe expanded it's not
that expanded into it it expanded by
virtue of creating it that's that's the
difference in thinking about the
expansion of bread and the expansion of
the universe okay what else do we have
enough Abu Salim asks could the universe
have begun as a black hole yeah I mean
Lee Smolin was mentioned earlier and and
Lee has an interesting theory that black
holes give rise to other universes in
some sense the interior
of a black hole opens up into a new
realm and he has an interesting notion
of natural selection among universes
namely that those universes that have
constants changed in just the right way
to maximize the production of black
holes thereby producing more universes
more children more progeny are the ones
that are better adapted and therefore
will dominate reality so he makes a
prediction that the typical universe in
this ensemble should be one whose
parameters masses of particle strengths
of forces are finely tuned to maximize
the production of black holes you know
you want to have a lot of kids in order
that you dominate the Darwinian
evolution the universe wants to have a
lot of extra universes produced in order
that it dominates that competition and
the way it dominates it in this
perspective is by having a lot of black
holes so yes it's possible I don't know
I've never been convinced of that idea
it's an interesting it's very creative
so I'd like the idea a lot but I am not
convinced that there's any real data
that allows us to fully talk about how a
universe would emerge from a black hole
nor how the constants of nature would
change as you pass through a black hole
a lot of details that have yet to be
nailed down before I would take that
picture seriously ok so what do we got
Andre and I'm drew Canole Sookie how can
one get into string theory after grad
school I would say get into screen
string theory during grad school if you
could I mean I think that's a that's a
good way of going about it
past grad school what can you do sure I
mean people change fields all the time
getting into string theory is more of a
challenge because it's the most highly
mathematical of all the theoretical
pursuits that you might have undertaken
and that means they'll have to learn
more and more stuff that you could have
learned as a grad student but you
probably didn't if you were studying a
different field not impossible to do can
be can be
difficult to do and ruhani asks what is
energy and multiplier fan says do you
love me
not your which answer which question to
answer first so I'm gonna I think I'll
just answer one of those what is energy
so you know energy is a very subtle idea
we throw the word energy around all the
time in in in basic physics class you
learn energy is anything that has the
capacity to do work work is moving an
object through a distance right so I'm
exerting energy to move an object
through a distance a force exerted
through a distance and um I find that's
not a bad way of thinking about things
but I think having an inventory of
energy gives you a feel for it so mass
is a kind of energy motion is a kind of
energy kinetic energy is a kind of
energy compress a spring or stretch of
spring potential energy is a kind of
energy energy from gravitational
potential you see its energy can be
turned into into motion so once you sort
of having your disposal some of the
examples of energy now you can say
energy is anything that I can acquire
from those ingredients through an
allowed physical transformation
potential energy to kinetic energy
nuclear situations where we can take
energy that's strong that's in a strong
nuclear force and turn that into kinetic
energy so it's basically anything that
has the capacity to impart motion okay
what else do we have here Stosh asks
Stosh I like your question genetic
plasma nuclear energy all types of
energy okay thank you
piping in on that PHR asks maybe this is
a good one to end on piata asks what is
life and and
again it's a question that you can gain
insight into by taxonomy by giving a
listing of examples of life well why am
i hearing myself talking oh I'm having
maybe this is a sign that I should go up
on self-talk what it was yeah what did I
do wrong did I hit a button
can i moot myself or should I sign off
is this the sign from the gods that I
should give up
feedback anymore alright I think we're
good do you guys still hear me out there
in the in the YouTube world or am I now
talking into the void let me know if you
can still hear me and also let me know
if you want me to to wrap this up I it's
uh it's 5:39 I figured I could go for a
few more minutes if you want it's it's
still light out here and I'm not gonna
do this in total darkness although I do
have some lights on in here too but what
was I talking about Oh what is life
let's see where that takes us so there's
some examples of life right human being
dogs cats bees insects birds dinosaurs
right so having the taxonomy and mine is
useful to thinking about life but it's
notoriously difficult to give an
ironclad definition of life I think the
definition that was on one of the
spacecraft that had near the record the
recording of sounds of planet Earth
described life as I think anything that
had the capacity to carry out Darwinian
evolution by natural selection I don't
know I don't that really helps you get a
feel for life but life is anything that
can carry out the processes of life is
kind of circular but life is anything
that can move it's something that can
metabolize right it can take an
ingredients from the world and turn them
into energy to power internal physical
processes so you know there all sorts of
criterion that you might put out for the
Bennett man there's all sorts of stuff
having that is an alert happening on my
phone it's a tornado coming seriously
you guys see this I may have to uh I may
have to sign off if the tornado comes
yeah this guy is turning kind of dark
but you know I think I'm in a relative
safe spot but anyway if you see me swept
away by a tornado you know that I have
gone to the Land of Oz or something of
that sort but yeah the the forces are
seeming to tell us to wrap it up but I'm
gonna those are wrong but my point is
there are many boxes that you can tick
such that a living system satisfies the
criteria in your list but I really do
think that life is a continuum it's not
that life is something that satisfies
this list of criterion rather if it does
satisfy this list of criteria then you
can call it life but if it doesn't it
doesn't mean that it's not life it might
mean that it is enroute to the kind of
life forms that we are more familiar
with but I think that life extends all
the way back and at some point in the
Darwinian evolution you get to a level
of complexity and refinement where it's
obviously a living system but I don't
think there's a place where you can say
that life turns on life is organized
complexity life I like to say is physics
orchestrated and if that orchestration
has sufficient robustness and complexity
then you have a living system and when
it doesn't quite have that you are
enroute and perhaps better thought of as
being along the spectrum that goes from
inanimate to animate not something that
necessarily turns on like a light switch
all right guys um the wind is really
picking up here and I see all my family
heading inside and they're probably
going to bar the doors if I don't get in
there in time so I think I'll probably
wrap it up here and that's just like one
more question that I just have to answer
and I'm scrolling through Oh Kent
Linkletter as is a Boltzmann brain alive
well yeah
I would say that in relation to the
question that we just had if you had a
Boltzmann brain out there in the void
able to carry out even momentarily the
processes that this great thing inside
of our head does and if that brain you
know has the thoughts that for instance
match my own if it's particulate
arrangement happens to mimic and
replicate the particle arrangement in my
head right now
I think I would absolutely call that
Boltzmann brain alive and after all if I
was able to grab that brain and stick it
inside a human body and connect it up
appropriately that brain would function
precisely as an ordinary human brain so
I would certainly characterize it as a
living system it might not live long
without the life-support that a body and
a planet can't provide but during the
moment of consultation that that brain
carries out yeah I would say it is a
living system ok so people are telling
me to stay safe I appreciate that please
go to the shelter I'm gonna do that
alright guys so this has been fun you
know a little a little shorter then then
perhaps we would have if the situation
hadn't changed next week maybe we'll go
for an even longer marathon session
until then you know watch until the non
till the end of done it's my book I mean
take a look at your daily equation
videos catch up on any that you've
missed let me know I swear I don't know
the level of rigor that you want because
sometimes I'm more technical than other
times and it seems like less people are
engaging with those but maybe it's just
a small core of you die hard
mathematically rigorous people that's a
fine thing too I don't need to reach a
lot of people with these as long as I'm
reaching people for whom they matter but
I'm gonna have a blend you know of
general ones and and more specific ones
as I've said always I'm not sure how
long I'm gonna carry on doing the series
I actually have to teach a course at
Columbia starting May 26 8 hey any of
you you're allowed to sign up for the
course unfortunately it is pretty darn
expensive it's what you know
universities do they have a lot of
expenses so it's not cheap to sign up
for my course but it is on my book until
the end of time it's called origins and
meaning you can search onto clumb
columbia summer school if you want to do
that I'd love to see some of you in that
but again unfortunately I've got no
control of this it does cost a little
bit of money or a lot a bit of money to
do that once that course begins it may
be harder for me to do your daily
equations so toward the end of May I may
look to wind this down maybe I'll call
your weekly equation if you don't mind
maybe do some videos once a week and
some live sessions once a week that's a
possibility but you know go check it out
check out the Columbia thing if you're
interested check out your daily equation
if this is new to you this is your first
engagement with this and until my next
video I hope to do it on Monday what am
I gonna do I don't know I think it may
do something in cosmology maybe I do the
Big Bang or maybe I'll do dark energy
that'd be fun to do tell me what you
like me to do on Monday if I see
something in your list I will do my best
to accommodate it okay